Charles Murray is the wh Brady scholar
at the American Enterprise Institute he
first appeared on the national scene in
1984 with the publication of the
groundbreaking book losing ground uh it
argued that the Great Society social
programs of the 60s and 7s worsened the
plight of the poor and the minorities
they were intended to
help uh I can think of a certain
socialist senator from Vermont and and
only slightly less socialist uh former
Secretary of State who could benefit
from Reading uh the book his numerous
other books include the bell curve
co-authored with the late Richard J
hearin coming apart the state of White
America and one of my favorite titles
the kin's guide to getting
ahead uh subtitled the dos and don'ts of
right Behavior tough thinking clear
writing and living a good life uh for
his talk today he'll be drawing on
themes from his most recent book which
is titled by the people rebuilding
Liberty without
permission uh for our final lecture of
this Hillsdale College National
leadership seminar please welcome
Charles
[Applause]
Murray I have indeed been a Hillsdale
regular I think my first appearance
before a Hillsdale audience was right
after losing ground came out so we're
talking 30 years that I've been uh been
uh speaking to to Hillsdale groups
including in Hill Hillsdale itself where
I think either I was marooned in the
snow once or I was about to be marooned
and it's it's always a pleasure the the
problem that I have had
historically with all of my books is
they aren't really ones that cheer you
up a whole lot uh I have I have said you
know it's it's competitive Advantage I'm
really good at describing problems and
I'm not so good at prescribing Solutions
today I have a little bit of both
because by the people is unique in this
regard the first half as is traditional
for Charles Murray book produces
clinical depression and anybody who's
listening carefully and the second half
is very
optimistic because in the long term I
don't think that we by we I mean people
who are devoted to limited government
and freedom can lose uh but the longterm
does not refer to the next few
presidential Cycles uh I'll get to this
later but we
have a really bad problem in so far as
the American project as it was
originally conceived is pretty much dead
that's the first part of the lecture and
the second part is that the
opportunities for restoring the American
project in a new
Incarnation are very good let me start
with the depressing part the American
project as conceived by the founders is
effectively dead what do I mean by the
American project you could give a long
political philosophical description of
it I think it's really very simple I
think the essence is the American
project was the idea that in people can
be left free to live their lives as they
see fit as individuals as families and
as community
with the government providing a peaceful
setting for that endeavor but otherwise
standing
aside when I say it's dead I don't mean
it's dead for
everybody and this is a case which I
think people in this room and and I
myself need to realize we actually live
our lives pretty much as we see fit
already yeah there are lots of problems
we run into there are lot the government
is a harasses US in various ways that it
creates problems in various ways but the
people in this room including me have
the resources to be able to do
workarounds uh sometimes we have people
that we hire to take care of some of
these problems for us in in other cases
we simply have the resources ourselves
to to buy our way out of a lot of the
ways in which the government gets in our
way that is not true for everybody there
are a lot of people in this country who
do not have those resources and for them
the government is intrusive in all sorts
of ways whether they are trying to start
a small business or operate a small
business whether they want to put a deck
on their on the back of their house
whether they want simply to get together
with their neighbors to put uh in some u
a play playground equipment in a vacant
lot so that their kids can use it in all
these kinds of of very pedestrian ways a
whole lot of people cannot live their
lives as they see fit furthermore I
think that the prospects for using the
political process to roll back the reach
of government uh are not good and let me
give you some reasons why the first of
these reasons is that the constitution
as intended by the founders is in fact
broken Beyond repair and this was this
is something I did not believe when I
first started writing the book I had
this impression that we had a series of
of constitutional decisions over a long
period of time that nudged things in the
wrong direction uh on a slippery slope
and we can nudge them back in the right
direction and I was wrong about that in
the 1930s from 1937 to 1942 there were a
handful of Supreme Court decisions which
did not nudge they just simply flipped
uh hugely important constructs of the
American Constitution in ways you can't
really reverse let me use the the most
most famous example of this is heling V
Davis that was the case in which the
Supreme Court of the United States said
that Social Security was
constitutional even though Social
Security did not fall under any of the
enumerated powers by any stretch of the
imagination and what the uh justices of
the Supreme Court did was to take this
phrase General Welfare which is in the
sentence introducing the enumerated
powers
and said what general welfare means is
that in addition to the enumerated
powers Congress can spend on anything
which promotes the general welfare for
those of you who are historians of the
Revolutionary and constitutional era you
will remember that during the
Constitutional ratification
debates the meaning of that phrase was
debated endlessly not with two equal
sides arguing whether it did or did not
confer this power on the Congress but
rather people
saying that better not mean that it
gives that general power and you had
Madison and Jay and the other Founders
including Alexander Hamilton who said no
no no no no it does not do anything of
the sort well the Supreme Court said
well actually it does problem is you
can't reverse that because if you got
nine ninos Scalia is or nine Clarence
Thomas' on the court who wanted to
reverse heling because it wasn't
constitutional they would be declaring
that 95% of all spending of the federal
government is unconstitutional no
Supreme Court can do that no president
would enforce it the Supreme Court's
legitimacy would be shattered and the
same is true for a variety of other ways
in which the Constitution does not mean
what the founders wanted it to mean but
we can't go home again
another way in which we can't use the
political process uh to roll back the
use of government has to do with the
regulatory state which I'm going to
spend quite a bit of time on
today this is because there have been a
couple of things that have gone on one
is that again through Supreme Court
decision it is now okay for Congress to
pass a very general law saying we want
clean air and then leave it up to the
bureaucrats to implement and create the
rules that
operationalize what the legislation said
that's new too that came about in the
1930s before that the the Constitution
very clearly says all legislative power
shall be invested in Congress of the
United States and what they're doing is
De uh delegating legislative power but
it gets worse not only do do the
Regulatory Agencies make up the rules in
effect creating legislation
they also act as police and courts some
of you may not know this I didn't know
it before I started writing the book If
the EPA let's say comes after you for
violating an environmental Rule and you
want to fight it guess what you don't go
to a regular court with a regular judge
with a jury of your peers you go to
What's called an administrative court
and the judge in that administrative
court because there is no jury is
appointed by the EP
a if if uh surprise surprise the judge
finds that you are in fact in violation
of this regulation and you appeal it you
go before a a an appeals court which is
composed of people appointed by the EPA
and if you finally manage to get out of
that into and and there are some cases
when you can finally get into a regular
federal court you have a supreme court
precedent which says well we are going
to give the benefit of the D out to the
regulatory agency's position if there is
any rationale whatsoever for the rule
that just made if this sounds C
Kafkaesque to you it is because it is
Kafkaesque but you are not going to get
the federal government to say wait a
minute we're going to start writing
legislation again that actually spells
out what we want the Regulatory Agencies
to do and the reason you aren't going to
do that goes to the third problem with
uh making progress through the Poli
political process and that is the
systemic corruption that now
characterizes Washington
DC I do not mean that senators and
representatives that we have now are
more venal or dishonest than they were
in the past I don't think that's true
actually what we do have is a system
which is systemically corrupt think of a
think of a
kleptocracy in a Central Asian country
or Southeast Asian country or sub an
African country how do they work through
bribes everything has to have a bribe
you can't get into an office to see
somebody unless you pay a bribe you
can't get the legislation to pass
anything unless you pay bribes but if
you do pay bribes you can get a lot of
things done you can get special
permissions for your company you can
even get special uh laws passed which
your competitor's ability to
compete with you you can do all sorts of
things if you spend enough
money if you substitute for the word
bribe campaign contributions I've just
described the Way Washington
Works uh I I suggest to any of you who
have a beef that you need the help of
your H member of the House of
Representatives to help you on try
getting his or her time to hear you out
unless you have made an appropriate
campaign contribution it will not with a
very few exceptions happen but if you do
make the right contributions and so
forth there are all sorts of ways in
which the outcomes that you get in a
kleptocracy are also the outcomes you
can get through
Washington what this means is that you
cannot get sweeping legislation that
rolls
back a whole lot of the overreach of the
federal government there is an economist
some of you may be familiar with a man
named maner Olen uh he had died some
years ago he was at the University of
Maryland he wrote a couple of seminal
books and what he was really saying is
that in an advanced democracy you have
sclerosis and the reason you have
sclerosis is because there's an
asymmetry between a special interest
that really really really wants its
special benefit and this large amorphous
thing called the American public sugar
subsidies we pay twice the world price
for sugar in this country and have for
decades why because of the sugar Growers
Lobby sugar Growers are what one 100th
of 100th of percent of the United States
but you can't organize the
99.999% of the United States to oppose
it it's really hard because even though
we're paying twice the world price for
sugar you can't get us to get up in arms
about it and hence every year the sugar
Lobby wins every year doesn't make any
difference how many Republicans have
been elected they just tried to get it
rid of it last year again for the eenth
time you can't mobilize it well if you
take the sugar Lobby and have 20,000
sugar lobbies each locking in its own
special privilege you have created a
system that is just immobile you cannot
get sweeping reform let me hasten to say
you can use the political process to
have better policy you can get better
education policy better welfare policy
better environmental policy in lots of
regards what you can't do is roll back
the power of government and that's where
we come of the good news I have a way
uh it it relies upon an analogy with the
Wizard of
Oz this is something that I cannot get
away with uh in talking to Millennials
because a whole lot of them have never
seen The Wizard of Oz however looking
out over this audience I think most of
you know what I'm talking about okay so
you remember that at the end of the
movie where uh Dorothy has been
terrified of this booming voice of The
Wizard of Oz along with her compatriots
I think it's uh the dog Toto right who
uh pulls aside the curtain and what do
you have behind there you have a little
old balding overweight guy this gets a
little personal at this point
um who is pretty
pathetic uh he's not this this all
powerful thing that he sounded like uh
when when you couldn't see him the
federal government's a lot like that if
the federal government comes after any
one of us individually because we have
violated one of the rules in its
172,000 pages of the federal code of
regulations we are
right to say we can't fight it and in
fact it's that plight of the individual
that got me the right the uh the
incentive to write the book in the first
place true story absolutely true story
we have a friend who is in a business
I'm not going to be more specific than
that that that hires a lot of uh aliens
from uh Central America as is does
everybody else in his line of work the
difference between him and everybody
else is he documents them he spends
something like 25 Grand a year on
visas even though he brings the same
people back every year and he pays for
their airf fars he pays good wages way
above the minimum wage uh he's a great
employer he's a great member of the
community but because he has documented
his workers he has become a visible
Target and he is relentlessly harassed
for example he does not have enough
native born Americans working for him he
can't get native born Americans to work
for him if the unemployment office sends
them out to interview because that's
part of the uh requirement for getting
unemployment insurance they sit down in
his office and say I'm out here because
they told me I have to but I don't want
to work here he can't get them well
guess what he has fined large amounts of
money for not having native born
American workers that he cannot get and
he said to them on one occasion I'm
going to fight this in court because he
was so angry and so
frustrated and the bureaucrat who was
making trouble for him said to him quote
you try that and we'll put you out of
business close
quote probably some of you in this room
have had uh similar experiences with
bureaucrats over the years and in fact
they could put him out of business they
could just bleed him dry as he if he
tries to fight it that made me
incredibly angry when I heard about it
and then I had what uh Epiphany is an
awfully big word to describe it but it
was pretty close to an epiphany
certainly I had an image in my
mind as the bureaucrat was saying that
to our friend of this mystery man
suddenly appearing wearing a black
pinstriped suit car in a briefcase
tapping the bureaucrat in the shoulder
and saying we are taking this man's
case we are going to litigate this to
the end we are going to make you sick of
the sight of us we are going to
publicize what's going on to uh show how
dictatorial you are being and by the way
that publicity will include publicity
about who you
are and at the end of it when you do
find him guilty because he is
technically guilty of violating your
stupid regulation we are going to pay
his fine this made me feel a lot better
just this image of this happening and
then all at once I said to myself this
could work what if you had a legal
defense fund sort of like a legal aid is
now for poor people but this would be
for ordinary Americans who are being uh
victimized by the government for doing
nothing wrong but having violated one of
their regulations having harmed nobody
just trying to go about their business
what if you
had push back against bureaucrats who
right now have no disincentive
whatsoever to bring these kinds of cases
what if you were promising to them you
were going to make your life miserable
as you go through trying to pursue this
allegation if you did that for a large
number of cases and established a track
record you wouldn't have to litigate
millions of cases every year because
once you establish the track record once
you establish your credibility all a
citizen has to be able to do is to go to
the harassing bureaucrat and say oh I've
got good news the Madison fund I call it
the Madison fund the Madison fund has
agreed to take my case and you're going
to got a whole bunch of regulatory
agencies backing off once they know
that's the case that's then the solution
it it says look we have a wizard of in
so far as it's the this wizard is very
scary to any individual but the real
power of that wizard
disappears unless you have
overwhelmingly voluntary uh compliance a
place like oia uh does not have hundreds
of thousands of inspectors and hundreds
of thousands of lawyers it has actually
a relatively small number and it's
responsible for 8 million workplaces so
the chances that you will ever be
inspected by OSHA
are very small but they aren't zero so a
lot of people go through a lot of uh
things that have nothing to do with real
job safety just because they're worried
about an ocean inspection what if you
could lift this from it from them and
you could do it the government cannot
enforce all these regulations with the
enforcement capability that it has if we
have systematic Civil Disobedience we
can't legally get things off the
books but we can make large chunks of
the Federal code of regulations de facto
unenforceable now civil disobedience is
a really
serious strategy to undertake it
requires a really good justification to
do it because the rule of law is in fact
at the foundation of
Freedom those of us who believe in
limited government depend crucially on
the rule of law to sustain freedom if we
had any other alternatives to the Civil
Disobedience I'm talking about I would
be going for those first I am saying and
this is what I spend the first half of
the book trying to document we really
don't have any options anymore and
furthermore we are actually in the same
position that the founders were in when
they wrote the Declaration of
Independence the government has exceeded
its proper role in such blatant ways
that it is not only our right but it is
our duty to change things for the better
and put government back into its prop
proper box uh it is quazi
revolutionary but the overreach of the
government compared to what the founders
had in mind is so great I think it's
appropriate that doesn't mean you can go
off Helter Skelter disobeying any law
you want on the contrary if you are
going to implement this strategy if if
you're going to have a Madison fund or
if you're going to have professions get
together and establish legal funds that
do the same thing so that dentists have
a legal fund that defends dentists who
have been uh senselessly harassed by the
government or a plumbers fund for
plumbers who have been senselessly
harassed if you are going to have these
kinds of things you have to pick and
choose when it's okay and when it's not
okay to ignore the law and in the the
book I have a whole chapter devoted to
some of the criteria that need to be
used in order to create the situation in
which you are you are saying to people
here are the regulations that we are not
going to back you up on if you break
them if you are a mind
owner and you have not followed
regulations on the strength of the
supports of tunnels in your mind we are
not going to come and defend you when
your mind tunnel collapses we're talking
about the many many stupid regulations
that can be ignored you want some
examples uh probably a lot of you in
this audience could Supply me with
examples but here are a few of my
favorites there is the company that was
fined for not
having the sign
poison on a shed to indicate the
poisonous material was
within the shed contained beach sand
ordinary beach sand but OSHA had
determined mined that in certain
grinding
operations that beach sand might not
necessarily but might cause certain
kinds of lung problems now none of these
grinding operations went on anywhere
within the uh plant that I'm talking
about but they were still fine for that
there was the case and this was told to
me just a couple of weeks ago after I'd
given a presentation like this it was a
dentist who said that she had been
forced to replace an expensive piece of
equipment
because it had a paper tag on it as
opposed to a metal identification tag
and I said you've got to be kidding me
on this and she said no I'm not kidding
you I had to replace it at a cost of
$5,000 then there is my favorite of
all uh which is the bartender a woman
who was fined for not carding a customer
here's a good case of a lot of the
problems with regulations it's not that
the regulation itself is senseless I
think it's okay and and appropriate for
there to be a regulation that says bars
can't run around serving alcohol to 12y
olds and and so you have you card people
because you have a legal agent which
they can drink that's
okay the person that she failed to card
was her
father I just think about that how how
could he not be old enough to drink you
know if she can be a Bart
he's probably got to be old enough to
drink that kind once again I said you
are kidding me right and said no she
wasn't kidding it was a $3,000 fine
which she did not herself have to pay
because the bar sort of under the table
said look if you will plead guilty to
this we will slip you the three grand
because if they go after us the bar
they'll charge us $10,000 in so that's
the way they resolved it these kinds of
really foolish either foolish
regulations or regulation that are
foolishly enforced constitute a
significant chunk of the federal code of
regulations and this is what we're going
after I have lots of criteria for
deciding that it comes down to this
here's the sort of the def defining rule
suppose this case gets
publicized will 90% of the American
people who hear about it be on the
defendant side that's the kind of thing
you go after where you have broad
agreement across political lines that
this is really really stupid so for
example even though I personally am
opposed to affirmative action and
probably there is a majority of the
American public that's opposed to strong
affirmative action you don't go after
those kinds of regulations because there
is you wouldn't get 90% agreement you
would have a very broad number of people
saying wait a minute violating that
regulation is wrong because uh that's
that's doing arm etc etc you don't go
after those you go after the soft
targets but that's okay because that all
by itself will do a lot to reclaim the
freedom to live life as we see fit uh
for people who right now don't have the
ability to do
it that is the specific strategy that I
propose to use to roll back a lot of the
the the power of the government but it
is just the beginning of what I think is
coming down the road as possibilities in
the
future I think that we are in a
particularly propitious moment in 2016
and the decades to come for having a
much broader assault on a government
that has gotten way out of control and
I'd like to to just give you a sense of
some of the
possibilities one of these possibilities
ARIS es from the increasing diversity of
cultures in this country now a lot of
times the increasing diversity of
cultures is treated as a bad thing that
we are not assimilating new populations
I'm talking about the arguments about
immigration and so forth and that we are
losing our national identity because of
that well there's there's lots of of
ways in which these things cut both ways
because it's not just ethnic differences
in cultures it's differences in cultures
within the
population here here we are in
California uh San Francisco has a
distinctive culture all its own it's not
a conservative Culture by any Shadow you
know Portland Oregon has a very
distinctive culture all its own these
are potential flash
points for people who are traditionally
on the
left to say to the federal government
the way we live is none of your
business uh here's a here's a good
example here is here is a portent of
what is coming down the pike and it has
to do with states
rights for the last 50 years states
rights has been associated with
Southerners who were trying to protect
their right to practice racial
segregation against the federal
government and it's had a really bad
name because of
that well just a couple of years ago the
the states of Washington and of Colorado
passed laws permitting the legal use of
marijuana that are in direct conflict
with federal
law and if there's one part of the
Constitution that has remained sacran it
is federal law Trump's state
law and yet they have implemented those
laws and there have been no influx of
FBI agents or other laws enforcement
Personnel from the federal government to
put these legal state legal operations
out of business because they violate
federal law why did this happen well you
see legalizing
marijuana is something that the
department of justice under Barack
Obama's administration is not all that
unhappy about this is
a states rights from the left and so the
Department of Justice said well as long
long as certain broad guidelines are
observed in these state laws we will not
enforce the federal laws against them
that's called a
precedent that's a really important
precedent all at once the federal
government is saying well you know maybe
states can do things that we have laws
against the federal level but we can
ignore those if they happen to be laws
that we don't particularly want to
enforce that can come back to bite them
in the ankle as time goes on because
there are lots of different populations
out there that have lots of different
ways they'd like to live and the states
are getting feisty about asserting those
rights and so are communities getting
feisty about asserting those rights and
the really good thing is it isn't a
bunch of right-wing crazies like us who
are out there saying this is the way we
want states to have more Authority we
want communities to have more Authority
it's people on the left this is the kind
of
potential Alliance that can be formed
across left and right I think
increasingly because and this is another
way in which we are in a propitious
moment people on the left as well as
people on the right are increasingly
aware of how utterly incompetent
government usually
is we all use the internet these days a
lot when was the last time you
voluntarily went to a government website
when you had a question if you have a
question about health you don't go to
the Department of uh Health and Human
Services you go to
WebMD and get an answer to it and you
get a good answer if you are required to
go to a government website because you
got to file a form on the internet what
do you always notice about the websites
of the government which they're really
bad and bad I mean clunky they don't
work very well they they you compare
that with the websites put up by
corporations these evil corporations
they make life very easy for you uh they
they they they make the services they
provide or the products they provide
easier to get easier to use and the rest
of it there is it's increasingly visible
to
everybody that you don't use government
to do anything for you if you have the
option of using a private service
instead and that's just as true of
people on the left as people on the
right
uh people do not voluntarily go to
government cafeterias unless they have
to okay they will go out and and eat at
the local McDonald's outside the door
rather than than stay in the government
cafeteria things small and large that's
true about that increasing realization
of the incompetence of government has
spillover effects on the potential
Coalition between people who disagree
about Which presidential candidate
they're going to vote for but agree that
actually they'd like the government to
butt out of of certain things that they
jointly would like to see the government
butt out of a second way in which things
are going to change for the better and
we are in a propitious moment has to do
with
technology and here we are at the very
beginning of what we are going to see is
possible four letters u b
Uber I don't know how many of you use
Uber uh I know that one of our leading
presidential nominees Hillary Clinton
said the idea of uber was quite
scary which I suppose it's true if you
if you're 68 years old and you haven't
driven yourself for the last 20 years uh
yeah I suppose it's scary to you but to
the rest of us Uber is great uh that you
you you go on you go online for those of
you who haven't used it there's Uber you
are on the app you need to get from
point A to point B you don't stand out
in the rain trying to flag down a taxi a
taxi when it finally does arrive is
probably kind of dirty inside and the
trunk is filled with stuff and the
driver may not know where he's going no
you you've got Uber you tell them where
you want to go you tell them where you
are you can see on the screen where the
cars are that come to pick you up they
then tell you such and such a car is on
the way driven by so and so here's the
phone number so you can call him to uh
correct things if he's if you've changed
your pickup location picks you up you
get in the car your credit card
information is on file with Uber already
so you just get picked up you're dropped
off you don't pay a tip you don't put a
credit card in a slot you just it's like
being picked up by an acquaintance and
dropped off where you want to go and not
only that and what I'm about to say now
is absolutely key to non-governmental
solutions to problems you rate the
driver and the driver rates
you so that the end of every Uber ride
Uber asks you to give a number of stars
to your ride and if there's anything
wrong you can downgrade it the fact is
that Uber drivers are scared to death of
getting anything less than five stars
which is the maximum number because if
they are even fours four stars with a
couple of them Uber's going to start
asking questions about what's going on
so they're desperate to have get a five
which makes for really cheerful polite
Uber drivers but if you are a jerk as a
customer uh that information is also out
there so when you put in a call for an
Uber car your information comes up on
the driver's screen and if it says this
person is really a jerk probably you
aren't going to get picked up it's
wonderful it's it's wonderful because
you're each rating each other same thing
goes for Airbnb I don't know how many of
you are familiar with that this is where
you rent a room in someone's home uh
it's like a bed and breakfast thing and
you rate the quality of the room and so
forth sometimes it's entire house you
are also rated about whether you left
the house a mess when you moved out
again and and and so you have these
Services being
provided by people who are
voluntarily cooperating with each other
but here's the greatest of all things
about
Uber it taught
us that not only is the government
theoretically the wizard of Oz it is
really The Wizard of Oz in its
powerlessness the monopolies that taxi
companies and City councils have
established throughout the United States
have artificially made it hard to get a
cab uh for decades but it has been
assumed well there's really no way to
break into that Monopoly for the same
reasons I described earlier about how
hard it is to get things changed in
Washington it never occurred to
anybody instead of trying to bre the
Monopoly what if you just show up and
start offering your service without
asking permission and that's what Uber
did shows up starts doing this uh and
and by the time the city council and the
taxi company Monopoly got their act
together Uber in many cities has become
so popular that there's a political
price to be paid for getting rid of it
that's exactly what happened in
Washington DC city council passed a a
motion saying Uber was illegal and you
know what
there are a whole lot of people in
Washington who take a whole lot of cabs
including people who are really powerful
and both left and right and they wanted
to keep Uber and the city council had to
back down those are kinds of ways in
which the technology information
technology is not just used for websites
and answering questions and things and
buying books it is being used to sides
pass to to bypass the power of
government and what we have seen with
Uber and Airbnb and the rest is just the
very beginning of what's coming on the
way there are also things that can be
done through information technology
which undercut the rationale for
government uh for government
intervention if you're talking about
1905 or 1906 when the first uh major
government intervention in in food
inspection occurred the Pure Food and
Drug Act you know what back in 1905
there was a really good
rationale saying it's really hard for
customers to know what's in this
supposed bottle of uh medicine or what
uh is uh what the quality of the meat is
and we really need the government to act
as a third party an honest broker who
will let consumers know and protect
consumers it would have made sense it
did make sense in
1905 it's 2016
suppose we
repealed the requirement for Meat
Inspection by the
government if Safeway were then to
decide gee we can make an extra 1 and a.
half cents uh per pound on meat if we
cut corners on its
quality it would be all over the
internet in 24 hours and Safeway would
go broke it it would be that fast if you
had uh if you had people trying to pass
off bad meat because there were no
longer any government inspectors what's
going to happen instead if you get rid
of the uh government's role Safeway and
everybody else will be putting out ads
saying you know what actually our
internal standards for inspecting meat
have been higher than the federal
governments for years now which is true
uh and and we uh here they are and you
are absolutely safe and you would
improve the quality of the product
rather than degrad it if you got the
government out of the business the
government would no longer have the same
rationale the government would no longer
the federal government would have no
longer the same rationale for
interfering in local Affairs it used to
be the case 100 years ago you did have
company towns that used hired goons to
intimidate workers from forming unions
you did have hired goons who would uh
not only oppress but sometimes kill
black people in the South because they
were not behaving the way that they were
supposed to behave these were real
problems you really did need to have a
government from outside which helped to
prevent some of those problems
today there is nothing that 60 minutes
and also all of the evening news shows
in local television stations around the
country love more than to discover
somebody who's behaving badly in that
kind of a way you have a vastly more
effective surveillance of bad behavior
now which can be kicked in
not by knocking timidly on the
government's door and seeing if they'll
do anything about it but calling up the
local news station and saying have I got
a story for you all of this has undercut
the rationale for government in all
sorts of
ways I said I was optimistic in the long
term and when I say that to audiences
and then I say in 200 years and they're
all thinking of John Maynard KES who
said in the long run we're all dead well
that's true but you you know what I
don't think that makes much difference
for a lot of us I think the problem with
being devoted to a
cause as the supporters of Hillsdale are
devoted to a cause is not whether you're
going to win right away but whether you
think you just are ultimately doomed and
it's never going to happen so if I think
no we're going to win eventually it's
not that important that it happened
while I'm around to see it and here's
the way I think about
it the advances in information
technology I just described 200 years
from now or even a century from now 100
years from now are going to be so much
greater than they are now we can't
conceivably imagine all sorts of other
kinds of technological advances will
have empowered the individual in ways
that we can't imagine
now uh in two in a 100 years assuming
that economic growth continues the
secular increase that has characterized
it since we first started measuring GDP
back in
1886 we are going to be unimaginably
wealthier as a society than we are now
now is it possible that we could have
leadership of such Soviet stupidity that
that economic growth stops yeah I
suppose it could happen odds are that
won't happen so you have vastly
increased technological capabilities
that Empower individuals you have vastly
more money sloshing around than you have
now it is inconceivable to me that under
those circumstances people will still
think that the best way to run Society
is with thousands of laws enforced by
tens of thousands of bureaucrats it just
doesn't compute as far as I can see in
the book I try to describe some specific
ways in which the log jab could be
broken but that it can be broken seems
to me to be Beyond
doubt and it's really important that
that we do
so you know we are not advocates for
limited governments because of abstract
political principles nearly as much in
my view we are for it because it is the
way that people live satisfying
lives it is also the thing that has made
the United States unique there are many
other countries around the world in
which I could live a satisfying life
just among the countries that I happen
to know person personally so it's not as
if the United States is the only good
place to live in the world but we have
been unique in that we are the only
nation in the world that was created
with a charter of Freedom as we were
that people ought to be able to live
their lives as they see fit free of
interference since the United States was
created no other company country has
copied us no other country has modified
its Charter so that it is more like us
we have been unique and we also
developed a unique Civic culture a way
for people to live together within their
communities that has no real counterpart
anywhere else in the world there are
lots of places in the world with
friendly people lots of places in the
world with wonderful traditions of
hospitality very few in fact no country
in the world which has the history of
people who happen to live in Geographic
proximity to each other
voluntarily cooperating to solve
problems and get along as the United
States traditional Civic culture
did if we go if we stop that and that
Civic culture
disappears we will have lost something
Irreplaceable no matter how many other
nice countries there are in the
world I think that the challenge for the
American people right now and I'm
speaking not only of those of us who
already love limited government but all
the people of all kinds of political
views who treasure the unique Civic
culture of the United States to ask
themselves how much they treasure and
what they're willing to do to defend it
because if it is lost that loss will be
Irreplaceable the good news is it
doesn't have to be lost it can be
redrawn in a new incarnation in a way
which once again will let all the people
not just the rich ones but all the
people live their lives as they see
fit thank you very
[Applause]
much we have some time for questions
please raise your hand if you have
one
uh we do have some organizations which
do what you suggested taking on cases
against the government I can think of
two several the Goldwater Foundation
Pacific Legal
Foundation I've been on the board of
Mountain State's legal F excuse me
foundation for number of years it's a
30-year-old our signature case has been
a affirmative action we took it to the
Supreme Court and we won
twice it doesn't really it has to be
redone every time but still it is out
there so it can be done these are these
cases are taken at no cost to the people
who can't afford
it the the work of Pacific Legal
Foundation Goldwater Institute The
Institute for justice is terrific and uh
many of you in this room are already
familiar with them here's the difference
between what I'm talking about what they
do they have very limited resources and
so they choose cases very carefully that
they can
win because if they win them they
establish a legal precedent that gives
them leverage they have done a fantastic
job the Pacific Legal Foundation uh
besides its affirmative action cases the
the the sacket case that went to the
Supreme Court establishing uh Property
Owners uh uh rights to uh to argue with
the EPA was a was a
landmark uh thing the first people I
went to since I live in the Washington
DC area not in the west coast when I
started working on this book was the
institute for justice to get to get
their help uh in doing it they do great
work I want to make those uh institutes
have vastly expanded power through the
kind of thing I'm talking
about I'm uh somebody else if I I'm
having a hard time seeing hands go up so
over here
okay uh yes um what do you think the
proposed Constitutional Convention could
make on the uh con constitutional crisis
the convention
States well as a practical matter I
don't think it's going to
happen and and furthermore I think it
was Justice
Scalia who said I think appropriately
in the 21st century given the
predominant political climate in this
country it'd be really scary to have a
constitutional convention because once
you had it you could not be at all sure
that the kinds of things that would come
out out of it were things that limited
government uh Advocates would want
actually given the the intellectual
climate and the rest of it you'd end up
if you aren't careful I think that
with a worse Constitution than we have
now so Point number one is I think it's
been a practical matter it's going to be
really hard to organize it number two is
keeping control of that Constitutional
Convention really really a dicey thing
to
do see I'm my pessimistic side is just
waiting for a chance to uh come out
again
yeah yes in the uh the first part of
your talk you seem to uh describe uh
campaign contrib tions is sort of an
inherently corrupt system but isn't that
an inherent part of our American uh the
way we conduct our democracy we we spend
our our earn the money we earn the money
we make to support the people who will
represent us yeah no there's nothing
wrong with campaign contributions uh as
a way of of giving voice to political
speech when I said systemic I really
meant it that way and you've you've
raised an interesting question that I
don't want to do a 10-minute Riff on so
let me say it real quickly back in the
1970s you had campaign reform which
limited the amount of money that
individuals could give and the purpose
of it was to take the influence of
really wealthy people out of politics
you know what the reality was before
there were limits on individual
contributions yeah you had some members
of Congress who were there because they
had a patron back in their home District
of South Carolina let's say um and
probably that Patron who gave a lot of
money had
particular interests that he would
really like that Congressman to vote his
way on but that's just one or two things
mostly he's contributed the money but
but 98% of the decisions that the
congressman makes are going to flow from
the congressman's political principles
which presumably were congenial to the
guy who gave him the money so in effect
the congressman was maybe constrained in
some votes on how he voted but not a lot
the unint Ed consequence one of the many
that happened with the limits on
individual contributions was it
energized the
pxs so before if you uh were Ardent in
favor of con conservation it was really
kind of hard to do anything with that
money that was going to directly impact
a vote on environmental
legislation but then you got the Sierra
Club you got the others all at once You'
got this vehicle for uh getting your
particular uh cause better represented
that also sounds okay Until you realize
that now every single vote that a member
of Congress takes has a whole bunch of
really passionate constituencies that
have been G giving money there there is
no such thing anymore as a congress
person who is free to vote his or her
conscience and not suffer repercussions
if they don't vote the way this complex
web of uh uh of special interest once
that's a really short cliffnotes version
not against campaign contributions the
system we've created has really gone
Haywire yes uh Mr Murray over here U
thank you for your uh Speech
particularly for your
optimism uh we're always have our ear to
the ground hoping that we can hear
something that will give us some hope
and appreciate it the one thing a
dimension of our condition may be a fact
that I worry most about at present is
the tens of trillions of dollars of debt
on the books and additional tens of
trillions of unfunded liability and it
makes me a bit skeptical about uh being
optimistic at all particularly if we
depend on uh future development of of U
technology and so forth so would you
comment on
that again you have a mirror side which
says this provides an opportunity as
well as a
Danger let's face it Congress is not
going to act on the things that are
creating this huge deficit until they
absolutely have to and they absolutely
have to because their heads and Trunks
and the upper part of their bodies are
hanging over the cliff that's what it's
going to take to get there but at some
point that's going to happen and it's
not going to be in the very distant
future given the projections for the
cost of government and at that point
there become ways of saying you know
what here's an alternative way of doing
things and you have to make major
reforms you don't have any choice and
here's a way you can do it that will
also incidentally be a way that gets
government out of people's
lives I am having a reissue of a book
that I wrote in 2004 that is coming out
a couple of months from now it's called
in our hands a plan to replace the
welfare state and the reason there is a
new addition coming out uh 12 years
after the first one is because what I
argued then which is for replacing not
not adding to but replacing the welfare
state with a guaranteed annual income is
now not only financially feasible it is
one of the only available ways that the
government can get out from under the
kinds of obligations it has now now I'm
not going to go into a defense of the
guaranteed annual income in this Q&A
period I'm simply say that there will be
opportunities as we approach that
Cliff knowing that there must be major
reforms because we are not going to be
able to pay our bills otherwise in which
Solutions more congenial to limited
government become practicable in a way
they are not now so I will persist in
that optimism having also acknowledged
what you implied which is you would
think think that the government would
finally respond when it's hanging over
the edge of the
cliff but maybe they won't maybe they're
too stupid to do that let's not dwell on
that
U uh Dr Murray you gave the uh
characterization of uh Federal
regulatory bureaucrats as uh the man
behind the curtain in The Wizard of Oz
my experience has been they're more like
uh the flying monkeys from the wicked
Rich of the West
um and I find those flying monkeys very
disturbing more so every day
because the example followed by the
Obama Administration in particular has
been that Federal bureaucrats are not
just buffoons enforcing ridiculous laws
but they're agents to punish the
opposition and that opposition is now
drill down to the mere citizen I'm
talking about the IRS thing I'm talking
about the Gibson guitar thing which
appears to be a retaliation against
political contributions but what do you
think in the short term of the federal
government particularly at the highest
at the White House level using the
federal bureaucracy to punish and and uh
destroy opponents thank
you well just to add to uh the potential
scariness of what you refer to I don't
know how many of you are familiar with
this facility in Utah that the NS is
building uh this is for storage of the
stuff it brings in and NSA basically has
the capability to listen to everything
oversee everything well I'm actually not
that scared about
NSA uh misusing the data but I am really
scared about all of that stuff that's
getting stored forever because I think
it is inevitable that politicians will
eventually start misusing
it
what what I'm about to say is uh perhaps
more hopeful than is
warranted but there's some basis for
it we're talking about really really
sophisticated computer capabilities
Information Technology we have I think
that most of the talent for that is in
the private
sector and you also have in Silicon
Valley an awful lot of people who are
actually quite libertarian
in Silicon Valley I know Silicon Valley
votes for Democratic candidates but
that's for reasons I think have very
little to do with political philosophy
and a whole lot to do with just what's
fashionable but in terms of of the way
they look at it you have a massive
amount of really high powerered skills
out there that is uh really hates that
kind of misuse of government power and I
think that they mobilizing that you
don't have to have you don't have to
have an organiz ation to mobilize it I
think that those hackers can probably
beat the kind of hackers that the
federal government can get to work for
it
so it could play out wrong it could play
out very badly it's very scary what the
Obama Administration has done crosses a
few lines that haven't been crossed
before but in many ways it's just an
extension of what the federal executive
branch has been doing over the last
three or four decades you're going to
have to have people in the private
sector rise up and and and block it
that's what I want to do with the civil
disobedience in the case of these
capabilities I think a lot of the
resistance is going to come from the uh
from the hackers out in Silicon Valley
hope so this will be our final
question uh thank you for the giving us
some optimism uh wanted to ask you uh
where I can learn more about the monroll
fund and is that already a practical a
practi
the Madison fund yeah i' name named it
Madison after since Madison was so
Central to the
Constitution uh the short answer is that
after the book came out I got all these
emails I mean lots of them saying you
know well I want to give money to the
Madison fund I I'm a lawyer and I want
to contribute my
services
and my response internally was to say I
write books you know I don't start comp
Le Lex entrepreneurial philanthropic
foundations uh but I am happy to say
that uh at least one person I know is
prepared to commit seven figures
substantial seven figures to as his
contribution to a Madison fund and I
think that there have I know that there
have been some exploratory feasibility
analyses that has started so I have
hopes that something will come of all of
this probably won't be exactly the way
that I well I'm sure it won't be exact
ly the way I described it in the book
but in all of these things that I've
been talking
about I'm not describing problems where
you have to persuade people who are hard
to persuade it's really hard to persuade
people who are social Democrats that
actually Libertarians or limited
government Advocates are right it's
really hard to shift them from
there to where we are it's not hard at
all to say you know the way they're
getting in our way is none of their
business it's just wrong there that you
can persuade and and that is a is a is a
response I've gotten from the book which
is very heartening it's not limited to
people who hold the political views of
those in this room it is a sense broader
in the American people of something
really essential about how this country
runs which has been l lost and that's an
easy sell and that's really good news
it's been great to be back at Hillsdale
uh thank you very much for having
me